hey guys this is vadim with max tech and
in this video i'm gonna answer the
question that you guys have been asking
me for days now and finally we have this
video of course we've been working
overtime i've got coffee right here
because i'm tired all right we have
eight gigs of ram on the m1 macbook pro
right here this is the base model for
thirteen hundred dollars
and this model has sixteen gigs of ram
this is the model that's fifteen hundred
dollars in this video i'm gonna be
focusing on comparing the differences to
see if
the extra eight gigs of ram is worth it
and also to see if this model the base
model with eight gigs is enough because
this new unified architecture for the
memory it's definitely so much better
and so much more efficient than intel
machines as you guys saw in our previous
videos when we compared the intel models
compared to the new m1 models so without
further ado let's get into it the first
test we're going to run is geekbench 5
which is very sensitive to ram or memory
so we have 8 gigs right here as you can
see 16 gigs right there let's go ahead
and start the benchmark now what's
really awesome about this video is max
was able to find an app that is able to
measure the sensors correctly right here
it's i statistica i think
right here we show the ram we show the
processor power we show everything and
i've also got the temps
so this one is at 27 degrees this one's
at 30 right now so that's awesome that
we found that now this is interesting
the eight gig model has less than one
gig free as you can see right here i
don't know if you can see that less than
one gig free whereas this one has 6.6
gigs free so this is actually using more
than eight gigs of ram to run this test
look at that this one has less than 200
megabytes of ram free look at that less
than 92 so it looks like it just used a
lot of ram for a test so it's definitely
being limited
all right we have our scores and this is
hilarious guys basically the same exact
score only two points off on the
multi-core
7463 compared to 74.65 so for geekbench
even though we saw that ram difference
the scores are identical all right just
because i'm curious i'm just gonna run
one run of cinebench r23
and i'll also open up i statistica to
see if there's any difference in ram
usage right off the bat we have less
than 500 megabytes free
definitely using it up and over here on
the 16 gig model
less than three gigs free so it's using
much more than eight gigs so we're
definitely getting an advantage here
let's see if it makes a difference in
the final score guys this is insane as
you guys can see on these temps this
one's at 59 degrees celsius this one's
at 57 while running cinebench this is
crazy because the intel models would hit
close to 100 degrees like within 20
seconds these are so cool the fans are
completely off and silent i i cannot
believe this alright we have our scores
and they're basically identical 7600
7600
no difference here at all so the ram
didn't really help but i am going to run
this again
just because i'm curious about the temp
so i'm going to run it a couple more
times and i'll get back to you guys guys
this is extremely impressive they're
both at around 70 degrees celsius
nowhere near the 90 to 99 degrees that
the intel models would always run while
doing cinebench i have my thermal camera
right here
as you guys can see
the 8 gig model is at 35 degrees celsius
it's pretty cool 36 degrees celsius for
the 16 gig model so they're basically
the same and this is running so much
more cool compared to intel models 70
degrees celsius that's that's nothing
the fans haven't even turned on
it's insane now let's move on to the
logic pro music production test we have
the new logic pro benchmark you can just
google it and find it previously we're
able to run about 94
tracks around that or
we ran it again and we were only able to
get like 85 tracks so i have them both
loaded up 95 tracks let's see if
having more ram 16 gigs instead of eight
will basically give you better results
so let's go ahead and run this test oh
that used all the ram
used all the ram they both overloaded
okay so i'm gonna turn some off here all
right i cut it down to 90.
let's run it again i mean this one's
only got three gigs of ram free so it's
using more than the eight gigs this
one's got like 121 megabytes free
i mean we're definitely using up that
ram they're not skipping a beat
all right they both made it all the way
through so i think i'm going to add
two more tracks
retest it they're both running 93 right
now as you can see the cpu percentage is
both at around 80 to 83 percent so it's
using a lot of the cpu and for this test
it's an overload test so if the wattage
spikes a little bit too high and you
don't get
perfect
computation or computing it'll overload
the system and so far with 93 we're
perfectly fine now this is interesting
the 16 gig model overloaded on 94 tracks
but the 8 gig didn't so it looks like
ram isn't a big deal at least when
you're running a ton of tracks now if
you have a lot of third-party plug-ins
that you know use a ton of ram
obviously you already know that so
you're going to want to go with this 16
gig model but in a test like this
really no difference now let's move on
to xcode programming doing a build test
and i'm happy to report that maxim
erimenko sent us a new updated version
of the max tech xcode benchmark and it
is working so let's go ahead and run it
all right they are both building and you
guys should see the cpu going up to 100
here there you go 100 right there 100
almost 94 actually it's not fully maxing
out that's interesting there you go now
it's a hundred percent both are 100
let's see which one finishes faster look
at that guys we're at over 3 3600 3800
on that build
only passing 3000 right now on this one
so so far there's a difference looking
at the ram usage this one has 5.4 gigs
free this one only has 500 megabytes
free 122 seconds on the 16 gig model the
8 gig is still going 136
so
136 seconds on the 8 gig
122 on the 16 gig so for this xcode test
the 16 gigabyte ram model of the m1
macbook pro is 11
faster than the 8 gig model now of
course this is going to change based on
how ram intensive your builds are in
xcode but to see an 11 difference with
16 gigs versus 8 is pretty refreshing
because so far we haven't seen any
differences so at least in xcode you do
get a little bit more performance now
it's up to you to decide if spending two
hundred dollars more for 16 gigs is
worth 11 more performance but what's
really impressive is that eight gigs
isn't really limiting it that much at
least not as much as people would expect
because when they see eight gigs like
whoa eight gigs is nothing but obviously
this unified memory is extremely
efficient so honestly it's not really
bottlenecking it so far alright guys
this right here is the ultimate test
out of all of the apps we've ever run
before
lightroom classic is the most ram
intensive app as you guys can see on our
27-inch imac for 2300 the 8 core model
there was a massive
massive difference just by upgrading the
ram as you can see in this chart now
what makes this test even more
interesting is that lightroom classic is
not updated for apple silicon it's still
running the old x86 model that's
optimized for intel so it's running
under rosetta to translation or
emulation so it's not going to be
perfect and it's not fully utilizing
that unified memory so it's going to be
interesting to see if 16 gigs really
helps this test out the first thing i
want to test is simply switching between
photos so a lot of photo editors do this
let's see if the 16 gig
is faster
all right guys
i don't know about you but
16 gigs
is not really making it have less lag
now these are large raw photos 42
megapixels and they also have a lot of
added changes and effects on them
so
really no difference switching between
them now i want to test out some
adjustments
look at that
perfectly smooth
for exposure contrast perfectly smooth
guys this is under rosetta if you
thought you had to wait for an updated
apple silicon version
you're wrong
i mean both of them are the same this
one was perfectly smooth ah it's so
impressive now for the main test we are
going to export
these photos and this is where we should
be seeing
a difference hopefully we should be
seeing a difference all right i got my
stopwatch ready right here and we are
about to export i am going to open up i
statistica to see the ram usage guys
this is insane look at that
we have less than 400 megabytes less
than 300 megabytes free of memory on the
16 gig model it's utilizing everything
same thing with the 8 gig so
this is obviously being limited in
lightroom classic and i can already see
the progress bar
advancing on the 16 gig model this is
interesting i'm now starting to hear the
fans
on both of them and that's because we
are using some graphics as well up to
around 44 of the gpu is used along with
100 cpu so
the fans are definitely on all right
guys i have the results and i don't know
if this is impressive or not
but the eight gig model finished in
three
minutes and the 16 gig model finished in
two minutes and 43 seconds
so you're really only saving
17 seconds
with the 16 gigs of ram even though we
saw that it was completely using all of
it
i mean so far the 8 gig model is very
impressive because that's not that big
of a difference but what will blow your
mind is that we already ran this test
with the 2020 imac the 27 inch 8 core
model with 16 gigabytes of ram just like
this m1 macbook pro it cost 2300
and it finished this exact test in 2
minutes and 50 seconds
this m1 macbook pro with 16 gigs of ram
is faster than the desktop imac with 16
gigs of ram that cost 2 300
now we are seeing a difference between
the 8 gig model and the 16 gig model but
to be completely honest
17 seconds that you're saving going for
16 gigs
honestly isn't that much i totally
expected a much larger difference
because this is running under rosetta
and this was using all of the available
memory the main takeaway for this test
is that eight gigs is not really
limiting you because it's running under
rosetta and it's almost as fast as a 2
300
imac that was just released like less
than six months ago now let's finally
get into video editing with final cut
pro now i have a five minute test it's
4k h.264 which is a very standard format
that a lot of youtubers use and this
also has extra luts and added film grain
and let's go ahead and export and see if
there's gonna be a difference in the
time now looking at our ram usage we've
got less than 700 megabytes on this
macbook pro less than 600 now
and less than three gigs
on the 16 so it is using more than eight
gigs to run this export test all right
they both just finished with the exact
same time for exporting this three
minutes and five seconds that is
actually very impressive you know why
because even the best i9
16 inch macbook pro took around 3
minutes and 20 seconds the reason for
that is because that speed on the 16
inch was limited by the video encoders
the gpu was completely fine
but these are limited by the gpus that's
because these new m1 macbooks have new
video encoders that are faster than the
ones that are in the 16 inch macbook pro
so these are blowing away every 16 inch
at least for regular 4k h.264 video
editing which is absolutely mind blowing
now to make it a little bit more
interesting i have a 10 bit hevc 60 fps
clip it's one minute on each of these
and i'm going to export this all right
there you go the 16 gig finished a split
second sooner but one minute and 12
seconds for both of these so for this
kind of task
no difference in ram all right let's run
one more test this is 8k
redraw a one minute clip which is going
to be exporting to
4k uhd so let's go ahead and
start it all right guys this is actually
very interesting the 16 gig model
the gpu is 100 percent maxed out as you
guys can see right there but on the 8
gig it's only running at about 80
percent
which means it's probably being limited
by the memory as you can see there's
about a hundred megabytes free on the a
gig
and about one gig free on the 16 gig so
it looks like in this more extreme 8k
red raw test we're finally starting to
see a difference in
video editing this is actually very
interesting because the 8 gig
should be maxing out the graphics to
export this as fast as possible but it's
not and because of that looking at the
temps the 16 gig is at 62 degrees
celsius right now
but this one's at 47. it's staying cool
because it doesn't have to do that big
of a workload just jump down to 42
degrees now just because i'm curious i
want to look at the temps here
the 8 gig is at 32 degrees celsius
compared to 35 degrees celsius on the
16. so this one's definitely being used
much more as i can see it's 70 degrees
celsius on the chip itself compared to
50 degrees celsius on the chip
wow this is a big difference it's being
used much more this is insane guys these
are the results that i have been waiting
for
the 16 gig is currently at 76 percent 77
the 8 gig is only at 16
guys the 16 gig model just finished the
8 gig is at 21
that is incredible i'm gonna wait for
this to finish while the 8 gig model is
finishing up i'm about to blow your mind
this 16 gigabyte m1 macbook pro for 15
hundred dollars finished the export in
five minutes and 59 seconds guess how
long the export took for the 16 inch
macbook pro with the i9 a core processor
and 32 gigs of ram with the 5500m
graphics that model is priced at 3500
3500 compared to 1500
with the 13 inch m1 macbook pro
that model took five and a half minutes
compared to this one taking five minutes
and 59 seconds keep in mind that the
5500m graphics is much more powerful
than the one in this model and with 16
gigs of memory compared to 32 gigs on
that 16 inch 29 second difference is
honestly not that much so if you're
thinking that 16 gigs is a limitation
not really i mean this is performing
close to the best 16-inch that is just
mind-boggling
[Music]
all right guys the a gig model is
finally finished with the export let me
remind you the 16 gig took 5 minutes and
59 seconds
the 8 gig took 13 minutes
and 57
seconds
so
the 16 gig model is over 2.3 times
faster in this crazy 8k export and that
is definitely worth the extra 200
dollars for the 16 gig ram upgrade now
let's finally answer the main two
questions that we have is it worth
upgrading from 8 gigs to 16 gigs of ram
well for the most ram intensive app
which is lightroom classic we only got
10 percent faster or better performance
with the 16 gig model which is honestly
not that much and even in xcode it was
11
faster with 16 gigs of ram now i
personally think that it's not worth
spending the extra 200 unless you're
extremely serious about squeezing every
little bit of drop of performance out of
the m1 chip because 10 performance
that's not a deal breaker for most
people unless you're doing this kind of
stuff all day and you need it to happen
asap however in the most extreme video
editing 8k redraw which is crazy footage
it is definitely worth it because you're
getting 2.3 times faster performance
with six gigs of memory but for anything
else for regular 4k editing hevc things
like that there really isn't a
difference so eight gigs is surprisingly
totally fine and it's performing
so well compared to the previous intel
macbooks even the 16 inch model so in my
personal opinion most people should be
fine going with the base 8 gig model and
they really shouldn't worry about
performance because it's doing
so well better than we expected and to
make it even better amazon is currently
selling the base model for 50 off so if
you're interested in buying this model
definitely check out the link down in
the description below now to answer the
second question
is 16 gigs of ram limiting i would say
no
because this is performing almost the
same as a crazy high-end 3500
16-inch macbook pro that had 32 gigs of
ram this is performing almost the same
with a weaker gpu with only 16 gigs so
apple's unified memory is extremely
efficient and it seems like 16 gigs on
apple's unified memory is similar to 32
gigs with the old intel systems so it's
extremely impressive and 16 gigs isn't
really gonna limit you so there you guys
have it hopefully this test answered
your questions on memory and if it
helped you out go ahead and click the
circle above to subscribe because we're
really trying to hit 500k subs before
the end of the year thank you guys so
much and definitely check out those two
videos of the m1 macbooks compared to
intel right over there thanks for
watching and we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]